it is indeed the last full day before
the 2022 midterm elections and what a
day it is a truly packed program and we
are going to be talking about in
significant detail tomorrow really what
is at stake in this election but for
today we are going to contextualize it
we'll contextualize it by looking at
some of the final Democratic and
Republican rallies and some of the final
polling as well and one bit of polling
that came out over the last couple of
days that is particularly disturbing is
the degree to which this country the
United States has fallen into a
veritable Cesspool of conspiratorial
thinking when you really don't need to
find such conspiracies to understand
what it is that is going on in the
country and as is often the case
conspiracy theories have some kernel of
Truth in their origin but take people
very much in the wrong direction in
terms of their beliefs and let me make
it very concrete for you a new poll
shows that 44 percent of Voters see a
secret cabal that is controlling the
federal government
when you look at this poll of 1 000
registered voters conducted at the very
end of October you see that 44 overall
but it's not that dramatic a difference
between Republicans and Democrats
um 53 percent of Republicans 41 percent
of Independents and 37 percent of
Democrats believe the federal government
is controlled by a secret cabal
the thing about this is you don't need a
conspiracy theory about a secret cabal
we know that overwhelmingly government
and Industry and regulators and the
world of Finance are controlled
by those very corporations and the
wealthy individuals that run those
corporations that's the it's not a
secret cabal there's no secret here okay
these are the folks who have run things
overwhelmingly in the United States
for over a hundred years you could argue
you know maybe there was a brief period
in the 30s and 40s uh during FDR when
um it was really the government was kind
of governing the wealthy to a certain
degree and not even really completely
the seeking The Conspiracy to control
secretly is what is disturbing in
particular here because you don't
actually need to look very hard for
who's really in charge there was I
believe it was a Princeton study and we
covered it years ago which found the
legislative desires of Corporations and
of the rich are much more likely to be
made into law than the legislative
desires of the average person
so we knew this already it's not a
secret it's out in the open and where it
gets dangerous is that you have Myriad
propaganda outlets and politicians and
others
who will take the kernel of Truth which
is there are entities and individuals
Beyond just the average people
whose desires are overwhelmingly
reflected in how the country is run
that's true
and then that's where you get into
Shadow government conspiracy theories
and we've seen every version of this
right now it's kind of hot with
Republicans and Trump has been
mentioning at rallies it's the marxists
the Socialists and the Communists he
doesn't know what any of those terms
mean doesn't know the differences
between those two those three terms but
he uses them that's who is secretly
controlling everything and then if you
think about it clearly you go and you
look and say okay if Communists are
controlling the US first thing we should
do is find Communists and then you go
and you don't find any there's no
Communists in positions of power in the
United States so you can very quickly
debunk it but that's what they're going
to and then you know the other ones
right the trilateral commission the
bilderbergs the Illuminati the Q stuff
and that theory about its pedophile it's
Democratic pedophiles who are
controlling the country it's the Jews
That's a classic as always so what's so
disturbing about some of this polling
is that
it is true
that not everyone's desires count
equally right your desires and my
desires for what we would like the law
to be don't count as much as the desires
of apple as brought to the government by
highly priced lobbyists that's true
but the secret cabal which lends itself
to all sorts of xenophobia and racism
and conspiracy theories you don't need
it it's all out in the open and of
course we know that when you believe in
the subterfuge When You Believe In The
Conspiracy Theory aspect of it
um
you often vote in ways that don't really
make any sense because you believe
things that simply are not true so
anyway that's context to some degree for
how people will be voting tomorrow I
have to uh take a step back I have to
correct something I previously said
in the past
I have been talking about Democrat Josh
Shapiro Josh Shapiro is the guy running
for governor in Pennsylvania Josh
Shapiro is running against Doug
mastriana
and in the past I have been saying about
Josh Shapiro not as a pejorative but
I've just been saying Shapiro is a
completely uncontroversial milk toast
boring Democrat and I've been saying
that in a positive sense I don't know
what I mean by that is the options for
Pennsylvania Governor are extremist
January 6th attending big lie repeating
right wing ideologue Doug mastriano who
will steal Pennsylvania's electoral
votes in 2024 if he gets the opportunity
that's that's one choice and the other
side is a completely boring
uncontroversial milk toast Josh Shapiro
who is just going to be very under the
radar and run the state of Pennsylvania
in a completely normal boring
uncontroversial way and I was saying it
as the choice should be obvious we need
Josh Shapiro Josh Shapiro over the
weekend appeared with Barack Obama
and delivered an absolutely fantastic
speech Obama level speech went
completely viral millions and millions
of views and I was wrong
I don't think there's anything milk
toast about Josh Shapiro he actually
seems like a fantastic candidate that's
not how we do things in this
Commonwealth or in this country
and that is not freedom
you know this guy loves to talk a good
game about Freedom right let me tell you
something it's not freedom to tell women
what they're allowed to do with their
bodies that's not freedom
it's not freedom to tell our children
what books they're allowed to read
[Applause]
it's our freedom when he gets to decide
who you're allowed to marry I say Love
Is Love
it's not freedom to say you can work a
40-hour work week but you can't be a
member of the Union that's not freedom
all right
and it sure as hell is in Freedom to say
you can go vote but he gets to pick the
winner
that's not Freedom critical issue it's
not freedom but you know what you know I
work for work for real freedom and let
me tell you what let me tell you what
real freedom is
real freedom is when you see that young
child in North Philly and you see the
potential in her so you invest in her
public school that's real freedom
that's real Freedom
real Freedom comes when we invest in
that young child's neighborhood to make
sure it's safe so she gets to her 18th
birthday that's real Freedom yeah I I
have to tell you
super impressed with Josh Shapiro over
the weekend here's one more clip of Josh
Shapiro talking about his opponent
[Applause]
this is a guy
it's a guy who doesn't respect women
here in Pennsylvania
in fact in fact in fact if you don't
think like Doug mastrian if you don't
look like him if you don't vote like him
if you don't worship like him if you
don't marry like him you don't count in
his Pennsylvania
[Applause]
you know how I know that
because I know where he was on January
the 6th right
he went there that day understand
understand he went there that day not to
hear a speech or protest he went there
that day to stop your vote from being
counted Josh Shapiro is really good I
actually you know I was feeling like we
just need to dodge a bullet by
preventing Doug mastriano from becoming
the governor of Pennsylvania and we do
but I actually the more I learn about
Josh Shapiro and the more I read about
his policy platform and ideas I think he
will be a fantastic governor of
Pennsylvania he should win it is not
close right now in the polling but
everybody should vote a former president
Barack Obama also very clearly
explaining the stakes
the only way to make this economy Fair
the only way to make our democracy
stronger is if we fight for it you can't
take it for granted and that starts with
electing people who know you
who see you
who care about you
who can walk in your shoes and see
through your eyes and know what it's
like to struggle know what it's like to
get sick know what it's like
to have to pay off student loans know
what it's like when things aren't just
handed to you but you got to work for
them
that's what you did two years ago when
you sent Joe Biden to the White House he
knows you he's been there he's fighting
for you every day doing everything he
can to put more money in your pocket to
make streets safer to bring more good
paying jobs here to Pennsylvania so
listen later you'll hear the types of
things that were being said at the Trump
rallies over the weekend but this is not
an election about whose policy do I
agree with slightly more okay this is
fundamentally about
which candidate agrees
that the winner should actually get to
do the job
and there are a lot of these people
running who are perfectly fine even if
their opponent gets more votes saying I
should still be the governor I should
still be the senator even though I
didn't get more votes and that's
extraordinarily scary let me know your
thoughts leave a comment on YouTube and
by the way if you're not subscribed to
the YouTube channel make sure you hit
that subscribe button at youtube.com
slash the David Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
I don't know what other podcasts you
listen to I don't know what other
YouTube channels you watch this
particular one depends on your support
to do what we do and I would love for
you to sign up at joinpakman.com I
believe tomorrow's election is not the
end I believe it is only the beginning
of what is going to be an insane two
plus year period of not because we want
to do it but because we have to do it
defending democracy democracy is under
attack and just you wait until you see
what these people are going to try to do
we need your support at joinpakman.com
and for just the next 24 hours you can
use the coupon code big voting 22 at
joinpakman.com we continue to follow
some of the most important races that
could determine who controls what for
the next two years one such race is the
Georgia Senate race where incumbent
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock is
trying to beat off an attack from former
football player Herschel Walker as you
know Herschel Walker can barely speak he
certainly seems unable to think he's not
able to explain his position coherently
on any issue he appeared over the
weekend with Fox News Trump brown noser
Maria barter Romo and it is truly
frightening that this could be one of
100 members of the U.S Senate being a
completely incoherent
individual which we have become
accustomed to but picking up on words
he's hearing elsewhere
without any idea how to use them here
claiming that they are bringing pronouns
to the military right now he's called
all men and women in blue Thugs and
bullets they bringing pronouns into our
military but yet they're saying it's the
Republican's fault yeah they're bringing
pronouns to the military I hate to break
it to your Herschel they're using verbs
they're using nouns they're using
adverbs it's they're even using
prepositional phrases in the military he
hears something that sounds like what
he's supposed to be saying and he
repeats it and he has no clue what he is
talking about in another moment during
this interview of all the different
threats to the United States that we're
dealing with right now
he says the real threat is that Raphael
Warnock will vote against the Keystone
Pipeline feeling now 48 hours away
well I feel I feel pretty good you know
when you have a president talking about
the biggest threat to the Democracy it
seemed to be electing a republican but I
want everyone out that is listening to
me the biggest threat to democracy is to
have him at the White House and the
biggest threat to democracy is to have
someone guys I mean listen I it is it
nitpicky that he can't say democracy
that he called it democracy three times
during this like is that you know you
you point these things out and these
right Wingers go David that's racist I I
thought you were the ones who said we
were racist when we see race I'm not
mentioning the guy's race I'm telling
you he can't speak or think
and now Republic oh you David what huh
the guy's completely incoherent like
Senator why not to vote against our
Keystone Pipeline oh God put us in an
international threat uh I think right
now that's a that's a threat and it puts
us in a threat when Warnock votes
against Keystone
explain that to me
uh it's a security threat we're going to
our enemies to ask for energy that's a
threat that's a biggest threat to the
marxistency there and also because men
and women sports which he voted for that
right that's another big threat to the
country men in women's sports an issue
affecting
zero point what 0.05 I mean come on guys
and Maria Bartiromo enables it they all
enable it by pretending this is normal
biggest threat to democracy is how the
people the Democrats right now leading
this country because they seem to be
taking this country in the wrong
direction yeah give me the indicators
Herschel give me the specific indicators
by which you could make that case so
here's the good news and the bad news
and they're both the same anybody could
win this race I know that many of you
were very worried because of this Gap
that was closed by Herschel Walker which
now has Herschel Walker ahead by half a
point on average I'm going to be very
direct and Frank with all of you
who the hell cares what the polls say
right now many people writing to me
saying David A lot of these polls are
right-wing biased Remington is a
right-wing poll as an example Remington
has Walker plus four here's the way to
think about it this thing is tied okay
some of the specific polls are literally
a tie like the recent Marist poll even
if you average all the polls including
the supposed right-wing polls
it's half a point that separates these
two
anybody can win if you believe that the
polls are biased towards Walker but that
early voter turnout favors uh Warnock
and but just go and vote if you vote in
Georgia if you believe Walker's really
winning then go and vote and make it so
that his margin shrinks by one vote
all we have to do is go and vote and we
will very soon know whether one of the
most humiliating realities about the
Senate will become a reality or whether
we can avoid complete and total disaster
Donald Trump held multiple rallies over
this final weekend before the 2022
midterms we already looked at rallies
which Barack Obama did let's now look at
Trump
Donald Trump's rally was so disastrous
half the crowd started leaving early
reporters reported that half of the
crowd was walking out as Donald Trump
was still speaking one of the new
totally propagandistic things that Trump
has brought back is flying in on his
plane this is the plane his own
followers funded for him to get
repainted and to get back in the air and
you would think at some point these
people would go
you know I donated all that money to
Trump he didn't do a damn thing for me I
still have no savings I'm still in this
terrible situation here in Latrobe
Pennsylvania but he's flying in on a
brand new painted plane maybe I should
stop maybe it's time to stop overt
fascistic propaganda
shows up with the cheering cultists
but they don't think about it they just
go yeah this is the guy I'm supposed to
be voting for so let's get right into it
inside the cult inside the cult Donald
Trump did something interesting he
referred to Ron DeSantis as Ron Des
sanctimonious showing us he was going
public with the civil war between him
and DeSantis party for the nomination
like nobody's ever seen before
let's see there it is Trump at 71 Rhonda
sanctimonia said ten percent now people
didn't like this later when we look at
the Florida rally that Trump did Trump
didn't invite DeSantis
but he did say vote for Rubio vote for
DeSantis in the not even 24 hours
between the Pennsylvania rally and the
Florida rally people went to Trump and
said that was not a good look
narcissists don't like sharing the
spotlight Trump is furious that DeSantis
refuses to say I won't run against Trump
in 24. so he went with Rhonda
sanctimonious Republicans told him don't
do that that's not a good idea and Trump
backing off of it by the following rally
Donald Trump wrongly claimed that this
Pennsylvania Supreme Court ruled
that he won the 2020 election there take
a listen believe that basically said we
were all right
two weeks ago a week ago you're
bored of Pennsylvania said they were
right the 2020 election with the respect
to the ballots and everything else the
2020 election was
not right it was not right it was not
allowed that is not what the
Pennsylvania Supreme Court ruled Trump
is lying overtly what the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court ruled about a week ago is
that undated ballots in the 2022 primary
were invalid 2022 primary undated
ballots they did not rule that things
were not right in 2020 and certainly not
that Donald Trump won Donald Trump
continuing to talk about 2020. and
you're all Democrat mostly I think just
about all Democrat Supreme Court oh
sorry this is the this is part of the
clip we just looked at okay let's
continue Donald Trump talking about his
relationship with the Chinese president
XI
and Trump's saying I call him the king
now are you if necessary
when I went to China because I actually
until
the China virus came in I had a great
relationship with uh president XI he's
now president for life I call him King
he says no no no I am not King I am
president I said no you're president for
life therefore you're the king as far as
I'm concerned yeah there are uh times in
American history
where for a president to say I basically
am calling this authoritarian strong man
the king that would be a humiliating
blunder for for a president or former
president to say
and the crowd cheers now this is how
depraved
and debased
the right wing has become
Donald Trump then exploding in an
unintelligible word salad about the
media being the enemy of the people and
Russia it's unintelligent it's diarrhea
of the mouth folks communism this is
getting to be what they're doing doing
with a Catherine engelbrechten everybody
this is like a communist country and the
people we're not standing for a
communist country well there is no such
country here in the U.S so you don't
have to stand for it or sit we came too
far because honestly they have nothing
going their policy is crazy the only
thing they do well is misinformation and
cheat on elections that's the only thing
and they're really good at that the
radical Democrats are locking up
pro-life and you know this you see this
the pro-life activists they're being
locked up all over the place
they're persecuting their political
opponents I wonder who
nobody a friend of mine said A friend of
mine said there's never been a president
that's been treated like you after he
gets you know when you get out of office
you go and these guys come at you left
and right on such [ __ ] you've never
seen anything like that
another thing is that the crowds are so
childish that when Trump swears
the crowd cheers like that's cool I mean
it's it's it's quite literally like
eight-year-olds on their political
Rivals remember they spied in my
campaign and remember they did not spy
on Trump's campaign just as a reminder
just as a reminder
Trump's campaign in 2015 and 2016 was in
touch with so many suspected criminals
and spies that because those suspected
criminals and spies were being
surveilled
Trump's people were coincidentally
overheard because they were in touch
with those suspected criminals and spies
it's out of this world stuff and Trump
just says oh they spied on my campaign
they spied on my campaign Trump then
talks about documents the entire
document thing and he tells lies there
as well new Air Force One now Air Force
One is actually two planes it's two
seven forty seven eight hundreds by the
way nothing more relatable than when
Trump talks about planes and private
planes and they're quite quite the plane
I will tell you in fact I can't even
tell you what's on this plane because it
might be top secret and they'll try and
say oh he violated it document he
violated a document listen
everybody's accusing Trump of of assault
now even the documents
it's violated every other president
takes their documents I'm the only one I
can't have a document but everyone else
they got them all over the place they
have them in Chinese restaurants and
bowling alleys you know that right now
remember that's also a lie what Trump is
referring to is there was one point at
which the National Archives actually
legally and officially rented a building
that previously housed a restaurant in
order to temporarily store documents the
archives had them the idea that George
H.W bush stuffed some documents in a
Chinese Laundry like in the in the dryer
it's completely absurd so then the crowd
starts leaving half the crowd reportedly
leaving while Trump was still speaking
they bring up memet Oz Mehmet Oz says
tomorrow before the Steeler game
call 10 people and make sure they vote
the only problem the Steelers didn't
have a game yesterday but Oz who isn't
even really from Pennsylvania has no
clue what's going on
tomorrow morning when you awaken
I want you to contact 10 people do it a
church two before the Steelers game just
find the time and here's the question
you're going to ask them
are you happy with the way America is
going right there was no Steelers game
yesterday Sunday Oz knows so little
about Pennsylvania that he doesn't even
know when the Steelers play and of
course actual Steeler fans I assure you
know when the Steelers play the rally
was also in support of Doug mastriano
Doug mastriano took a different approach
which was during his brief uh moment in
the in the Limelight during the rally he
just groveled before Trump which is
really what Trump likes Pennsylvania Mr
President
Pennsylvania loves you
we need you
he was such a great president that even
Vladimir Putin behaved for four years I
mean the Vladimir it's amazing
absolutely fantastic Pennsylvania three
days away from Victory we're gonna take
back our state recently yeah so
mastriano was on message he was just
praising Trump that's what you're
supposed to do and then lastly and this
was really weird Trump brought up
Christian televangelist lunatic Kenneth
Copeland and it got really weird
there are things
this great state of Pennsylvania
Liberty was born here
I've been accused of being a Christian
nationalist
our first president
1789.
this is not slowed down by the way this
Bible it's 17th chapter of Genesis
where God made Covenant with Abraham
and he read that
and he bowed his knee oh God and he
prayed
anyway
I won't play the full two minutes uh
Trump was completely bored during this
and very clearly regretted bringing up
Kenneth Copeland absolutely deranged
rally we were there our correspondent
Luke Beasley was on the ground in
Latrobe we'll have those clips after the
break remember
if you watch our content make sure
you're subscribed to the podcast on
whatever podcast platform you use it's
free and make sure you are subscribed on
YouTube I just got updated numbers from
October
3.2 million individual people
watched our clips
aren't subscribed on YouTube If just
those 3.2 million people subscribe we
would immediately be tied for the
biggest Progressive YouTube channel on
the internet
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
I have something extra special for you
today our friend and correspondent Luke
Beasley was in Latrobe Pennsylvania for
the Trump rally he interviewed a dozen
people and we are going to look at it
right now now a few things that I want
to say here and this I'm not joking
about this
when we we're not even playing
everything for you there's some stuff
Luke sent me that seemed so obviously in
the wrong category and I'll tell you the
categories in a second that it just felt
like I just shouldn't even use it okay
but as a general thing
by definition
if you survey the Maga movement they
have delusional incoherent beliefs that
in any other context we would say that's
mental illness and so you go and you
interview people and they all kind of
seem mentally ill
and it really raises a question for
people who are wanting to say let's hear
from this movement there's tens of
millions of these people we want to talk
to them and then you talk to them and
you go can I even air this because they
seem mentally ill am I is am I is am I
doing something wrong by showing that
this is what they say there's obviously
cult beliefs in people that are just
sucked into a cult and then there's
ignorance and there's mental illness and
it's a Venn diagram I don't know exactly
where each of these people are but it's
something we really think about and I
cut out some stuff
so let's just start Luke first talking
to a couple of women one of them says
Trump is currently the president The
Other Woman in the middle kind of
doesn't seem to buy it and Luke does a
really good job here let's let's start
I'm not sure and by the way it was
really windy so at certain points
there's just like wind noise Luke did
the best he could
even his president really that's the
Tucker Carlson psychotic laugh
so she says Trump's the current
president he will be back any day under
military now look at the look on the
other woman's face she's starting to say
I may be nuts but I'm not as nuts as
this lady
whoa okay
filter out
is attacking Biden's performance as
president
but he's the real president
yeah Luke why is that so hard for you to
understand she is
yes he's the blame for inflation
no
I believe there's a show going on I'm
believing he's letting this happen to
show people what what this world would
be without
actually God's letting this happen
exactly do you guys understand what's
going on
Trump is the real president under
military oh so he if the President is
responsible for inflation
inflation must be Trump's fault not
bidens no Trump actually God God and
Trump are allowing Biden to pretend to
be president to show you if he were the
real president he would make inflation
go up which he did even though he's not
the real president why won't people just
accept this Luke's like all skeptical as
if this doesn't make sense he totally
has command Biden is completely
hello have you talk have you heard them
talk who votes for someone like that
this ain't real this is not a real thing
okay well
I'm just gonna make this prediction to
you because I believe it Donald Trump is
going to take back over every executive
order that Biden put in will be going
that very second he takes back over yeah
and you were saying I heard the
beginning that the military was going to
do that yes the military is going to do
it so Trump's going to do it the
military is going to do it everybody's
doing it
is that a cult member is that an
ignorant person is that a mentally ill
person I'm not sure
I'm not sure here is a woman who makes
what I call an indivisible argument and
that's these are particular types of
arguments that make it really tough to
talk to these folks that is our right as
an American that our votes count and it
did not count on the 2020 election can I
uh press y'all or ask all about that
specifically so
with all the evidence that I am you know
hearing a lot from people here that they
believe that and feel like they've seen
that evidence why for someone who's
trying to strictly go to things that
they know can be verified has that not
been shown up in any of the court cases
that have been done plus any of the
audits that have been done among the
many exception there's corruption they
weren't audits that you know counted the
votes
um I mean what's going on an audits
understand what's going on these this
these are indefeasible arguments you
can't defeat them okay the example I
gave on the stream is as follows someone
comes to me with tears in their eyes and
then say David sir there's a tiger in
the room with you right now be careful
because in the studio right in the
studio with me right now there's a tiger
and I go oh okay I don't see a tiger let
me say Tiger's invisible okay invisible
tiger is unusual but fine let's do this
let's put baby powder down on the floor
so that because the invisible tiger
still has mass and volume as the tiger
moves around it will disturb the baby
powder on the floor and they'll go no
it's weightless it's a weightless
invisible tiger and then I say well at
some point this tiger is going to need
to eat let's put food down on the floor
so even if we won't see the tiger
because it's invisible and even if the
tiger also doesn't have any weight or
mass so it won't move around the baby
powder that's when it eats we'll see the
food being eaten I go no it's a special
tiger that doesn't need to eat that's
what these women are doing they will
always say no no but the audits weren't
done correctly and the judges were
corrupt
um
I mean it was an audit in a sense but it
wasn't an audit to actually right you
know it wasn't an audit that was going
to put Trump in the White House is what
she means the votes and the errors that
that went on during you know the
election I mean all along the world the
reason why I have a hard time believing
some of these claims is because like the
corrupt point
you would maybe make more sense if a lot
of the judges that these cases were put
in front of uh were appointed by Trump
and so I guess is it even them yes
um well a lot of people that were
appointed by Trump
um really I mean backstabbed them yeah
exactly so it doesn't they became
corrupt after Trump selected them here's
a guy who just straight up doesn't
believe the election results we're
seeing um kind of a phenomenon going
into this big terms it's very different
than others where a number of GOP
candidates have indicated kind of you've
probably seen the gas like are you gonna
concede if you lose and it's like no if
we lose it's probably because the
Democrats stole it is that a mindset
that you guys share
you want to answer anything budget oh I
definitely think it was stolen I always
think that they could tell I always
think that July and I'll never believe
that it was legit
interesting that is something that a lot
of times I'll say in conversations like
what would I have to show you or pose to
you that would change your mind on that
particular issue
I don't think there is anything to show
I remember looking back when they were
showing all these people at the election
places where the uh votes were and
everybody's running around covering up
Windows and stuff nobody wanted them to
see him I mean who even knows what she's
talking about people covered windows so
therefore Trump actually won then he
interviews a guy who seems dead set on
repeating multiple times that he does
martial arts martial arts clearly very
important to this guy who also by the
way is wearing an ultra Maga shirt this
is rickshade
mix smart
big in the news right now about the
investigation going on into him based on
the documents he had in my life it's
nonsense I think the justice department
right now is is totally uh corrupt at
the top I actually know some I train and
mixed martial arts uh we know and
getting close in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu I
know a lot of people in law enforcement
I don't think the middle level people in
FBI are crook crooked but the upper
level we've never had anybody weaponize
the Justice departments against their
opponents like Joe Biden's doing right
so what's interesting about this one is
that this is verbatim stuff that Trump
says verbatim they've weaponized the
justice department it's never been done
etc etc not particularly interesting
other than that but understand the cult
followers are paying very close
attention they're getting the exact
terminology from Trump here's another
guy who you know again I don't really
know what he's talking about totally
incoherent
us were born or our parents or ancestors
were born or was it the Native Americans
in the beginning or the white people the
original occupants the reason you hear
Trump speaking in the background by the
way is half the crowd was leaving while
Trump was speaking so there were plenty
of people to talk to while the rally was
going on America and then they got
pushed out right now
I love hip-hop culture hip-hop is like
embredded into me embred it I like that
that's a nice portmanteau of uh embedded
and bred into me it's been embredded
into Me Maybe the guy's just hungry
maybe a black soul a white body not sure
but I still have my soul and like the
soul of America is like slowly
dissipating yep so he had opinions about
things here's a guy who believes that
the Vatican is actually controlling
everything this one's really weird what
do you want to hear from Donald Trump
tonight
make America great again and what has
made it not great what has made an
upgrade is what's going on right now
open borders High inflation uh
everything that's going on right now
just diametically opposed the economy
the tax diametically opposed again they
just make up words they're totally
confident make them up totally confident
make it's diametically 86
000 IRS agents I mean we have all night
I mean the moon will set tomorrow by the
time so like he said there's so many
issues less zero in on one uh inflation
are you saying you blame Joe Biden for
inflation and you stop fossil fuels and
the country's running out of diesel in
17 days and no trucks no boats no play
nothing's going to be moving yeah you
might want to open up fossil fuels I
think this is coming
I think it's coming from the Vatican the
vatican's meeting he hesitates before
dropping this bomb they were world
leaders and at Mount Sinai Joe Biden is
getting his marching orders from the
Jesuit oath if you open up to Jesuit and
this might be a little crazy to these
people I don't really care Google to
Jesuit Oaths that when when Joe Biden
was elected president he opened up on a
wait a Jesuit priest on a Jesuit Bible
we've had two Roman Catholic presidents
this country and Joe Biden has taken
orders just read the Jesuit of that
explains so much about yeah so that's
that's pretty Bonkers stuff here's one
guy who just was Furious and started
swearing wearing an a huge huge hat uh
tell me about what you saw what you
liked I liked everything everything yep
and I want to say so but I can't say it
but
Democrats
because they're scumbags
what have they done to help this country
you're young yeah the regulation Act is
lowering prescription drug costs as well
a change
why is she that in your mind
all right anyway I won't stick with it
the guy's just swearing so much we have
to keep bleeping and then here's the
last guy this is then we got to the Q
Anon guy uh
I'm pretty far down to Rabbit Hole so I
don't know what I think right now so
what does that mean describe that for me
well it's just the whole everything
that's going on in the world and it's
been going on in the world and I mean
[Music]
I mean a lot of gyms we'll call
conspiracy theories you know just for
that heck of it for the game what would
you say your most wild conspiracy theory
would be and and Luke's instincts
impeccable there to go right in for the
most Bonkers thing
um
I guess there's really not a wildest one
I mean they're all conspiracy theories
until they are one proven true or the
masses believe them so I mean there's
there's been some wild ones over there
over the time you know with all the
child sex trafficking and Donald Trump
being the first president to fight
against that it's not a conspiracy
theory it's the truth so child sex
trafficking huge problem totally agree
with you that should be addressed it's
the connection I guess to like it's a
Democratic party who's doing this and
Biden's in the back room it's good
versus evil it's it's not Republican
versus Democrat there are a lot of evil
people in the world period whether
they're Democrat or they're Republican
rhinos and and they're bad for the party
bad for the country and does Trump's
relationship with I've seen before he
died bother you at all I don't think so
that's that's good huh there's
pedophiles everywhere it's Republicans
it's Democrats it's all of them we got
to root them out oh yeah Trump was
friends with Epstein is that a problem
no no no and watch what the guy says he
comes up with Trump was probably
Undercover
I don't think so imagine it doesn't
bother me because I if anything I would
think that would be like a us you know
uh an inside you know I mean like he was
on the inside getting Intel there you go
same thing he did with the uh the mafia
people that stayed in his hotels and
they were getting information back years
ago and Trump playing I've seen I think
so yeah interesting this gets even
crazier and we'll have the full clip
online but that one was really wild so
really really good job by Luke Beasley
you can find his YouTube channel make
sure to subscribe go to davidpackman.com
Luke and you will find it all all right
final event we're going to cover from
the weekend is the day after on Sunday
Trump did another rally in Florida Miami
Florida for Marco Rubio he did not Rally
for Ron DeSantis Rhonda Santos was not
invited although Trump did say re-elect
Ron DeSantis after people were mad that
he called them Rhonda sanctimony
the energy was particularly scary at
this one now often at the rallies Trump
is sweating and dripping but this one
actually had pouring rain we'll get to
that in a moment
scary energy and Trump's starting with
Nancy Pelosi whose husband recently
needed skull surgery because of a
lunatic right-wing attacker who bashed
his head in with a skull listen to what
Trump says this is this was just a cabal
this was just a group of people where
crazy Nancy Pelosi by the way how's she
doing lately how's she doing
where crazy Nancy Pelosi has the votes
how is she doing she's probably
extremely traumatized from what one of
Trump's followers did to her husband and
then even more disgusting they start
chanting lock her up about Nancy Pelosi
she hasn't been charged or she's not
even being investigated for a crime
under Biden Pelosi Schumer and the
radical democrat congress Florida
workers and families are under siege
Locker up right I mean they're for due
process and Law and Order and lock up a
woman who's not even being investigated
for any crime truly truly dangerous
Trump then did his uh racist dog whistle
about Mitch McConnell's wife Elaine Chao
Chicago to be a lot tougher
Coco Coco Chow you can have them both
Coco Chow is uh Trump's latest uh sort
of uh xenophobic dog whistle about
Elaine ciao horrifying stuff and the
crowd just I mean totally they're
completely unfazed by it Trump did as I
mentioned get enough backlash about
saying Ron de sanctimonious about Ron
DeSantis on Saturday night so by
yesterday afternoon he did the absolute
bare minimum and was like yeah yeah
re-elect Ron DeSantis governor
[Applause]
he did it he held his nose but he did it
and then we'll talk about
um uh this in a different context but
Donald Trump also talking about how much
suffering there has been
for his own children imagine that they
are the real victims here
and it was a person named Don Trump Jr
[Applause]
and he's great and he's great you know I
have to tell this one story because he
said he goes I could tell he's probably
heard me tell it a couple of times that
much but to show you how evil these
people are
so don went to Great school he went to
the Wharton School of Finance all this
stuff good student he was great he was
no problem whatsoever he's just a good
young guy
and I decided to go into politics I said
you know life is too good everything's
perfect let's screw up your life a
little bit okay
and so I take my family along with me
and uh that you know they've really
suffered when you think of it but they
they don't have any second questions
they've really suffered his family
really made the sacrifice Donald Trump
does tease that he might announce his
candidacy for president tonight which
we'll talk about later I will probably
have to do it again but stay tuned
it's quite a cult here as you can
imagine
[Applause]
and then he drops this about Ohio
tonight
there you go
that's pretty good thank you
stay tuned to tomorrow night in the
great state of Ohio yeah so there's a
report that Trump's going to announce
next Monday we'll talk about that in a
moment and then lastly it quite
literally started pouring during the
rally and Donald Trump made a big deal
out of the fact that he was heroically
staying out there to speak to his
followers
and just two years ago we had a red
China Russia and North Korea in chat
[Applause]
[Music]
weren't going to do anything against us
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway it was pouring and Trump was
soaked and they all made a big deal out
of how heroic it was to stay out there
these rallies are extremely dangerous
the people are weaponized today we will
have competing rallies Barack Obama and
Trump Trump's in Ohio I forget where
Obama is we will have them live later
okay we're going to take a quick break
if you watch us on YouTube and you're
not yet subscribed make sure to
subscribe subscribe to the podcast and
we'll be back right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right I've been saying for some time
I think tomorrow's election is the
beginning I don't think it's the end of
a phase I think it's the beginning of a
phase it's going to be the beginning of
a phase in which Republicans take
whatever wins they get tomorrow and
they're going to get some we don't know
how many we don't know what they'll
control but they're going to get some
wins tomorrow and they're going to use
those wins overtly to try to set up a
presidential election in 2024 where they
can't lose and what I mean by that is
even if their opponent gets more votes
they will try to find a way to still get
their candidate in the Oval Office it is
increasingly looking
like Donald Trump maybe that candidate
axios has published an exclusive report
that Donald Trump is planning to
announce his candidacy on November 14th
Jonathan Swann reporting former
president Trump's Inner Circle is
discussing announcing the launch of a
2024 presidential campaign on November
14 with the official announcement
possibly followed by a multi-day series
of political events
uh why it matters Trump and his top
advisors have been signaling for weeks
that a 2024 announcement is imminent but
the discussions reached the point that
allies are blocking off days in their
calendars for the week after the
midterms and preparing to travel
Trump long planned to announce shortly
after the midterms even toyed with
announcing before November 8 to try to
get ahead of Rivals
in recent weeks Trump has been inching
closer and closer to straight up saying
that he is running
now it is possible that he will indeed
announce on November 14th it's also
possible that he will announce tonight
and the reason I say that is he straight
up said it last night at his rally in
Florida let's take a listen to what he
had to say I I will probably have to do
it again but stay true
so the crowd cheers for a while and then
uh in a moment we'll turn the audio back
up Donald Trump says keep an eye on my
rally in Ohio tomorrow that's tonight
and we're going to be live with that
rally indeed uh take a listen to what
Donald Trump ultimately said about it
[Applause]
foreign
that's pretty good thank you
stay tuned to tomorrow night in the
great state of Ohio stay tuned we have a
big we have a big rally there
for JD we have a big big rally yep so it
may be tonight it may be next Monday but
at this point it doesn't seem as if this
is all for nothing it does appear as
though he is setting up a run
and when I say this is the most
important midterm election I've ever
covered
a huge part of the reason is because
it's a setup election oh that that
almost got that almost got dicey it's a
setup election for 2024. and
I believe that the next two years are
going to be completely insane and we're
going to need to really be on our guard
because by sheer stupidity to some
degree they failed to really come close
to stealing it in 2020.
they're going to be way more prepared
this time around
and we need to be ready for that I'll Be
Live on YouTube twitch and Facebook
tonight with the Ohio rally also we've
got an Obama rally and then we will have
live election results tomorrow night we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P here's a guy who really
doesn't like that I talk and comment
when I do coverage of rallies last night
we covered uh we we tried to cover the
Bernie rally and we covered the Trump
rally and this guy doesn't like that I
sometimes say things and he makes an
interesting point about my
qualifications to have an opinion
you're laughing because you're part of
the problem
and you've never been overseas all
you've done is sit on your skinny little
ass
and done nothing with your life I I've
been overseas plenty of places I've been
dozens of countries I don't know what
they're talking about except talking to
a microphone you've never squeezed a
trigger on anybody
oh that's true no if he means I haven't
been overseas with the military killing
people
that guilty is charged I have never shot
anyone the caller is correct about that
that being said I don't know why I need
to have shot people
or shot at people
in order to have opinions about things
that's strange I don't know where else
this individual applies that
uh
Mr dentist
I know you want to do my root canal but
have you ever squeezed the trigger at
people overseas you haven't oh well that
by no means okay very very dangerous and
sick people we have a great bonus show
for you today Twitter has started
advertising its page verification plan
for eight dollars a month oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad we will indeed talk
about it on the bonus show New York City
employers are now requiring salary
ranges to be posted I like this I like
this even as an employer and I'm going
to tell you why and then lastly the U.S
defense intelligence report on UFOs will
soon be made public I will tell you what
some people are expecting what I am
expecting and we will delve into it a
little bit more so much going on in the
next 24 hours the election is tomorrow I
will be live tomorrow night starting
between 7 and 8 Eastern on YouTube
twitch and Facebook with election
results we're going to go for a while I
don't know how long I hope you'll join
me
tonight we will be live with multiple
rallies starting at 7 30 PM Eastern also
on YouTube twitch and Facebook it is all
happening on those platforms so it's all
free I'm selling you nothing
follow us on Twitch for free
subscribe to the YouTube channel for
free like the Facebook page for free so
then you can get if you want you can get
notifications when all of these live
streams happen
a very very big 24 to 36 hours in
American politics that I I believe will
be of massive consequence going forward
see everybody then and of course to get
today's bonus show simply sign up at
joinpackman.com